好了下半节我来说一下AB实验系统的设计可能也就20分钟吧先说一下AB系统的设计准则其实我们为某一个用户做实验的话我们会给它只分配到某一个实验值所以我们要保证那个用户分配的实验值的稳定性就是它在APP的生命周期内要不它命中A要不它命中B然后在使用过程中不能发生变化
如果发生变化对我们的那个AP实验进行分析的就是分析的结果会有很大的影响当然如果我们一旦给他就是做实验一旦某个用户命中A或B在实验放量的过程中和以后这个实验没有下限之前他永远都是命中某一个组如果他在变化成其他组的话其实对我们的实验分析也是造成很大的影响的所以AP的
第一个实验的设计准则就是实验值一定要保证稳定第二个就是我们实验去获取就是像服务端获取那个分流吧分流的过程中是因为是一不请求的一不请求就会导致有些实验在取值的过程中它可能还没有拉取到对应的那个分流结果所以这个时候我们会给它默认分配一个叫默认组默认组我们是不进行上报的
如果默认组我们不上报的话其实那个对于我们那个上报的实验结果它那边去做统计的时候也不会对它造成影响其实就是这个用户没有对于那个AB来说这个用户其实就没有做任何实验也不会收集它的任何实验结果OK那个AB实验其实分两种就是我们做AB实验一般是一种就是
第一种是设备维度的实验一种是应付维度的实验设备维度的实验其实比较好理解我们这个设备一旦命中了某个职那么它在使用的过程中永远都是这个职然后后续的实验其实没有下限的过程中它永远也是这个职这样就保证了它命中值得稳定性那个用户维度的实验其实稍稍有些不同它会发生变化的每一个用户它在自己的用户生命中期之内
会有自己的实验值是稳定的当然它切换到不同的用户其实你VIP的用户命中了某个值它切换就是退出登录然后另外一个人登到了非VIP用户其实他们的值不能互相通用OK我们是怎么保证用户维度的实验值得稳定性的呢
首先我们在拉取就是拉取实验分流结果的过程中如果实验结果还没有还没有请求到那么它已经请求某个实验它第一次为default刚才说过了default我们是不进行上报的对分析结果不会造成影响ok它有可能在拉取这条线是用户正好拉取到时机用户拉取到之后我们去获取某个实验值2它是可以直接获取到了
当然后续的过程中我们再次去获取实验质疑它永远都是default的OK 这是用户登录的过程当然用户登录登录完之后它的身份是A它可能退出登录退出登录的那一刻其实它的所有的实验质就会被清除掉就是非登录用户非登录用户我们也会对它进行分流非登录用户跟刚才登录过程一样它有可能
从后端获取到某个职当然他获取实验值的时候可能能拉到也可能就是获取的时候还没拉到没拉到的时候一样刚才是default拉取到之后去获取某个实验值能够使用对应的实验值当然我们再次登录的时候跟前去的流程是一样这样我们就能保证他用户在自己的用户生命周期内他的实验值就是稳定不穿足
其实AB最主要的一个准则就是不串组OK说一下我们是怎么保证端上进行不串组的因为在程序启动的时候我们去向后端请求分流结果一般我们做的实验是要不是设备维度的实验我们之后这边设备维度是通过client ID去取分的就是client ID唯一代表一个设备
然后我们一个UID唯一代表一台唯一个用户然后我们通过这个首先判断有没有UID和ClientID如果没有我们去获取请求请求者当我能拿到了UID和ClientID的时候我才去请求分流当然我就向后端服务去获取分流结果分流的时候我们可能能请求成功也有可能请求失败失败之后我们会
5秒重视继续去拉那个AB请求直到成功当然这个也可以就是言论老师刚才说的一个指数推避这一块也可以加指数推避防止服务器压力过大导致雪崩OK 那说一下请求成功的过程请求成功的时候我们就从服务端拉取到它的那个分流结果它会拉取到所有的那个该用户的那个分流结果
我们会把它缓存起来放到内存中当然同时我们也会放到磁盘中进行一次缓存这个时候业务方通过API去获取他的实验他关心的实验我们会先从曝光内存刚才说了就是我们会保证它的生命周期内进行稳定当然用户伪度的就是用户伪度的就是用户生命周期
设备维度就是APP的启动生命中期它会先进行曝光内存中去查找曝光内存中如果不存在这个对应的实验值它会从内存缓程中去请求请求完之后它更新曝光内存然后进行对于这个实验进行上报单个实验进行上报然后并且更新到曝光缓程中后面我们再去请求这个实验值它永远从曝光内存中去请求这样这个
它的生命周期内一旦命中了这个一直在曝光内存中当然它的曝光内存中如果不存在刚才还说了还是继续从内存缓程中去请求这样就能保证了刚才说了这个是设备维度的用户维度的是它的用户生命周期内它的分组可能会发生变化所以如果用户退出登陆就是跟刚才那实习图一样它的曝光内存是被完全清除的
因为每一个用户有它自己的曝光内存它退出登录了它的曝光内存就已经清掉了进回到一个新的用户新的用户有自己的曝光内存当然这个新的用户刚开始没有请求任何实验质的时候它的曝光内存也是空的随着它命中不同的实验它的曝光内存就逐渐被填充这就是我们端上其实设计的很简单但是就完全可以达到那个AB就是保证
端上不串组然后设备维度和那个用户维度的那个分流结果ok这就是我们端上是如何设计的说一下分流上报分流上报这一块我们做了一些优化主要包括两两三方面主要哪三方面呢第一是我们一旦用户命中某个实验值其实随着它放量的过程它的实验值其实我刚才说过一直是稳定的
所以我们会进行一带格的请求一话就是在这个我们没有新的实验的过程中它一旦命中之后去判断与救的那个它的实验值是否相同就这个一带格如果相同的话他们就不会不会那个从服务端进行拉取直接从内层中就是从缓层中去取值这样就节省了大量的流量成本第二我们实验轮巡是实验是轮巡合并上报的
其实我可能同一时刻命中了三四个实验验我们并不会每一个实验单独上报我们会把它就是轮巡合并成一个数据结构batch log然后进行上报降低它的请求评次也进行了一些节流的操作第三就是我们上报有可能会失败失败如果失败的话其实那个
AB进行分析的时候它就会丢失一些就是用户可能享受到某个实验值了但是其实我们没有收集到我们会提前上报前将它进行存库减少丢失率当下一次启动的时候如果它如果成功了就从库中把这个上报删掉如果失败了它会进入到后台的时候会尝试重新上报或者是下次启动的时候进行上报这样我们就能够降低它的
丢失率就能保证AB那个服务就是能够尽量的获取到用户真正的那个实验结果要不业人老师说实验都快使劲然后整个这块话我一来说我来补充了那好就是我们的实验其实有两个可能扣单同学也需要关注的点吧第一个就是叫空转期就是说我们在实验上线前呢
会先对用户进行分组这个分组的话其实它有一个均匀度的问题就是因为每一次分组你都是随机的这种随机可能也有一些不随机的点在里面比如说
我们去比如说拿一个电商来说我认为这个挂湖道的销量怎么样可能是我产品决定的对吧但是呢如果的分组还有一组里男性偏多有一组里女性偏多那其实这个对于这个分组就是一个不均匀的可能男性偏多的会更关注就是那个挂湖道可能是因为这个分组导致的这个实验结果对其实显著就是可能
但是这个显著它的实验其实是有问题的所以分组不合理导致的对所以我们会做一个空转器的概念这个空转器就是在空转器里我也会设一些指标然后那个理论值就是所有的组里面的空转器的这个指标应该都是相同的或者是类似的
这样我认为它这个分组是均匀的所以会有一个空转器的概念所以这个分组一定要提前进行然后有让它空转的时间然后后面的实验才是科学的对 第二个的话就是分享一下北京星指标就是我们在做实验的话可能会有这样一种场景你比如说首页可能大家都在用但是A这个
A业务可能做的实验对A业务本身的收益非常大但是对B业务的收益就是偏差的那这可能就会影响到B业务那B业务可能会跟A业务下掉实验对就互相可能就白倒起来了那这个时候谁说了算呢
就是由北极星指标说了算这个是行业一种通用教法吧那这个我也是先现学现卖啊因为我们其实啊整体有啊专门的这个后端这个设计的老师来做这些东西啊主要今天觉得这个分享给移动端老师其实还是有一些价值的啊我们做的这个北极星指标呢
肯定是一些公司认定的核心指标比如说DEU或者是收益这个取决于就是公司看中的东西是什么可能会设计七个 八个这样的北极星指标这认为是公司级别了不管你这个实验的你自己认为的收益是正向还是负向那对于北极星只要它是负向那就证明你对于这个公司的APP而言它是一个负向指标所以你这个实验是不可能放权量的
反过来说也是一样如果你本身的收益不大但是你发现北极星指标找了很多那实际上你也是可以把它放开了因为它对于整体的指标是一个正向的对大概是这样一个东西对其实这个北极星指标其实我看过一个叫什么互联网就是产品的必修课好像提到过这个北极星指标对其实可能现在有很多
那个书都会介绍一些北极性指标其实实验还有很多就是我们公司有一个那个数据科学家对对对他真的很强就是整体这里面其实有非常多的算法比如说分流他是有算法的然后整体各种指标的计算等等其实他会都都有一些对应的算法和系统来来去设计
对其实如何做科学做实验其实有很多的门道的就是实验前的准备怎么分组怎么跑说还有实验后的实验报告还有什么很多依类策略这些东西就不展开讲了大家可以后面去研究一下我这边那个AB差不多就介绍这些正好控制大家20分钟